welcome to the dave ramsey show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios
it's the dave ramsey show where debt is
dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place
of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice
i am dave ramsey your host dr john
deloney ramsey personality best-selling
author
is my co-host and he talks to folks
about all things mental health whether
it's relationships and boundaries crazy
relatives
uh crazy looking at you in the mirror i
don't know whatever it is you can we'll
help you with it here and of course we
uh
we'll help you with your money stuff in
your life as well so it's always a good
time with dr john around here open
phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five that's triple
eight
eight two five five two two five
kaylee's gonna start off this hour in
dallas texas hi kaylee how are you
hi i'm doing good are you having a good
day i am better than i deserve how can i
help
well i have a two-part question it's
about um how to pay out
how to pay back our emergency fund um
we pay a thousand dollars a month on our
student loans
and we had to use 900 recently of our
emergency fund to pay for a car problem
so we were just wondering if it makes
more sense to use most of our
thousand dollars this month to pay that
back immediately
or if we should use a smaller portion of
that for the next few months to pay back
slowly so we're not skipping a month or
paying loans
you're talking about your little baby
step one one thousand dollar account
yeah okay yeah you gotta stop paying on
debt until you rebuild that if you used
it
because for the same reason you wanted
it there for the same reason you wanted
it there to start your baby steps you
want it there to continue your baby
steps right
thank goodness you had that there when
that little 900 bill came up or it'd be
new debt
right right so that's yeah you want to
stop everything go back to baby step one
finish it and then go back to baby step
two again get your get you a fresh start
so how you guys doing okay we're doing
great we've paid off about 11 000
in the past few months very good what's
your household income
um about 41 000 okay
very good excellent actually so is that
super frustrating or was it one of those
that yeah
of course it's frustrating but was it
come on man we got such good momentum
or did you and your husband smile at
each other and say
hey we got emergency fun yeah i mean
we've said a prayer thanks that you know
this isn't killing us we have it
and we can just pay it off this month
and keep going so
yeah what a great attitude man good for
you that's awesome that's perfect
and that's that's the way you you know
if you get these ideas and these
principles that we talk about
in the rhythm of your life instead of um
being
like white-knuckled and forced um
and that's the way you're doing it
you're just this is a rhythm we said a
prayer thanks thanks money thank you god
the money was there
thank you god we got the money to put
the money back and thank you god that we
get to keep going
to the next thank you god oh here we go
you know i mean and that's that's that's
kind of a rhythm to that
i've heard people when they call in and
they got that 1000 emergency fund
then the thing happens and if they throw
up their hands as though the cosmos is
against them
and we're always telling them no that's
the point that's why you have it right
it's for emergencies for that moment
right yeah that's good for you kaylee
four well done julie is in denver hi
julie how are you
hi dave thank you for taking my call
sure what's up
um i have a question about being
considered for a habitat for humanity
house
cool and we are seeking council we're on
baby step two
um it sounds like a sweet deal
but i'm not sure it's a great idea so i
wanted to
see what you thought about it okay
different chapters have different
terms that they use for the process
and so what how does your chapter work
i'm not 100 sure we're still in the
early
um interviewing process but we are being
considered
okay i'm wondering if it's a
like if we got into the house um the
payment would be
about 600 a month which is great
um so they're not giving you a house
free and clear they're giving you a
house that has a debt against it correct
yes
160 000 mortgage okay
and what is the benefit of it being a
habitat house
that's what do you mean i'm sorry i mean
you could go buy a house for 160 000
mortgage without habitat right yes
so why habitat what are they giving you
uh opportunity is what it feels like
because
the market in our area for a house this
size would be
near 300 000 okay so it's half off it's
half off
but i'm not sure if you actually gain
the equity
and ever have the chance to sell it yeah
some of them don't and that's why you
need to learn the terms
okay and uh some of them you you get the
home but
uh and if there's any there's all kind
of wacky stuff on the default and other
things
and the the programs are meant to be a
blessing but what they're
pushing the reason they build some of
these uh
i guess weird terms and
into the payment plan and into the
mortgage and into the sale
and so forth is they've had a recidivism
problem they've had people get into the
homes and fail
yes and so uh like a lot of them so
that's how we've gotten involved just to
help them learn how to handle money so
when they get a free house or a half off
house or
whatever they don't end up going and
buying six big screens at best buy on 90
days same as cash and then end up losing
their house
and that kind of crap has happened too
much
with habitat habitat is a wonderful
organization and they do
really really good work but they're just
trying to
people's behaviors have to change uh
even if you gave them a free house
they'll screw it up right right your
behaviors don't change and so
that and you so what they're trying to
do is not be enablers they're trying to
be real helpers
and so their their spirit is good uh i'm
i'm an admirer of habitat we've done a
lot of work with them
uh through financial peace university
over the years we've worked
here in the nashville community very
closely with them
but again they you need to learn the
nuances of
the terms and i don't mean terms as in
definitions
i mean what are the the term what is the
restrictions
on the equity and the sale and what is
the payback
and can you refinance later and it not
be in there
and you could get you could get just
stuck in some of these deals and again
they're well-meaning
but they don't but if things all work
out well it's not as much of a blessing
as it sounds like sometimes depending on
how they put the
the process together because they're
gonna limit the sale or they want some
of the equity back
if you do sell it or if you refinance
you you know you've got to refinance
through
the portion of the equity that they gave
you so that they can move on to the rest
of the houses and build them and
it's just it's it gets real complicated
so dig
in there and learn what you're getting
into you're very wise to ask
a lot of questions and make sure that uh
that the blessing is not so mixed
i don't want a mixed blessing yeah i i
didn't know
i didn't i'm learning just now the
public thinks that they just gave them a
free house
that's right and they don't and there's
a lot of hardly understood
they've never occurred to me now that
someone could get a free house and turn
around and flip it and sell it and
yeah there's going to be all kinds of
caps and restrictions yeah and it should
yeah because the purpose is to give
someone that doesn't have a home a home
and and the benefit of home ownership
it's not to make
you know not to be watching cable tv and
go flip this house let's do habitat
woo-hoo
you know have a place to come here so
it's it's you know
but they've had people try to scam the
system and they've got
they got to put some protections there
absolutely yeah so they're not bad
people but you need to
you need to really know what you're
signing up for and love it and it's
smart to do that and so
and then you can decide if it's right
for your situation dr john deloney
ramsey personality my co-host today this
is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
um
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country or have a
better life
the army national guard can help get you
there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
so
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
tax season is upon us i know
try to contain your excitement yeah no
one likes doing taxes
especially after a year like 2020 no one
likes doing taxes
it's a hassle to begin with and then you
get to give money to the government
which is always a
fun thing because they're so efficient
with it
and then you get free tax software tools
which gets you knee deep into the filing
process and sucker punch you with add-on
fees
credit card pitches and the opportunity
to finance your refund at rates that
would make
a payday lender blush who
you finance your refund for 90 days
before you know you go ahead and get
your refund instantly and then they then
you assign your refund and it pays off
your loan
you know however quickly the irs would
have sent you your refund and they
jack you who man it's like well it's
like buy you've seen these things online
where you can buy a shirt
and pay three dollars a month or
something yes yeah it's the same thing
if you
actually add up the interest rates on
that crap it's like 800 percent
i mean but nobody well it's just three
dollars i just paying a few dollars to
get my money early
because your child your child you cannot
delay pleasure you're getting
killed you're getting sucked into these
people there's a better way to do it
ramsey smart tax our team's brand new
tax filing software will help you file
with confidence
with ramsey smart tax you get up front
pricing and a killer deal by the way try
17
no tricks ever you can do the premium
for 38
i mean it's pretty incredible get rid of
your taxes get rid of the frustration
don't get ripped off don't get sucked in
text the word tax233789
ramsey smart tax text
tax 233789
zack is in charlotte hey zach welcome to
the dave ramsey show
hey dave how you guys doing better than
we deserve man what's up in your world
uh i i need a little bit of help uh i'm
trying to figure out how to set some
boundaries with my roommates who are
very irresponsible with money
and i know that conventionally you'd
probably tell me just to leave
but the other issue i have is my wife
does not will not allow it
at the moment i'm trying to deal with
that with marriage counseling but until
i can get that
solved i need to figure out how to set
the boundaries so that i don't have to
keep cleaning up life will not allow
you to leave your
your responsible roommates is that what
you just said
yeah yeah okay so understood walking me
through
wife plus roommates yeah that's to start
with i'm already confused
uh the female roommate is her best
friend
of since they were kids uh we live with
her and her
husband and because of that particular
relationship dynamic she does not want
to leave the same household i'm fine
with staying the same vicinity i love
these people
but while we live in the same house they
keep making irresponsible decisions with
money
i keep having to clean up the mess and
i'm getting sick and tired of kind of
trying to end up
living with them is this like a like a a
commune do you all have sheep
and like chickens what are y'all doing
you have like a solar panel
[Music]
uh what happened was uh so what happened
yeah pretty much um no this is pretty
back in the end of like 2018 start of
2019 my wife and i almost separated
because of marital issues
okay that's a surprise but uh
and you guys thought hey i know i know
what can you do i know what can help
we got to get roommates no you she moved
in
did you move in with them or did she
moved in with them
uh kind of both what happened was after
after the separation when we got back
together and decided we were going to
try to work things out
her friend invited me why don't we try
moving out to north carolina with them
we were living in colorado at the time
of the separation
the town we lived in had a lot of toxic
people that was part of the issue
and her friend was going to try to get
her into some good counselors that would
help her out
because the counselors in our area are
not very good
and we moved out there and then through
the financial
stress pre-dave and then the
pandemic and stuff we weren't able
to get our own place or better the
situation
and it kind of evolved to where she just
doesn't want to leave at all
she wants if she had her way she wants
to live with these people for the rest
of their lives like we get a house
together stuff like that but
they're irresponsibility that's not
going to work so zach
you're your marriage is in trouble and
you know that right
oh yes i know that okay so
i don't like because i'm happy about it
i'm not happy about that that's right
that's right
so do you have there's two separate
things here one is to answer your
question do you have legal
responsibilities to clean the mess up of
these roommates
meaning did you sign the lease and
they're just okay then
to set up the boundaries there stop
spending your money to clean up their
financial messes
okay i wish there was a more complex way
to do that but you need to sit down and
say
from this point forward i'm not bailing
out the home
for your part of fill in the blank bill
um uh rent etc what is the financial
arrangement
um for you to live there you pay
normally
apparently says we go 50 50 on the
rent and the bills and stuff issues
right now
one of uh the husband of the other
couple
he is currently unemployed and we're
waiting to get a new social security
card so that he can get a new job
somebody stole his wallet a few months
ago and
then he got fired we've been trying to
replace it but it's just
taking forever because of the virus
okay i say we because i did shell out a
few bucks to help him i still have some
money to help him get his birth
certificate so that he can get it
and that's what we're waiting on so we
can get the so what
what is your income
uh like what do i do for a living or
what do you make a year
uh roughly 38k what about your wife does
she work
i know she doesn't work you have
children
none that are she's got a daughter but
she's not in our custody
okay so why does she not work
uh she's got really bad social anxiety
and back problems
and
i feel that saying this i'm not sure if
it's a matter she can't or she won't
okay that's fine i'm trying to get her
into counseling
yeah so
dave feel free to bop me upside the head
here at this point
zack i'm gonna let my wife know in 30
days i'm gonna move out
it's not a helpful it's not a safe place
for your relationship
um it's not a good financial arrangement
you're running a household of four on a
38 000
income and your marriage is
deteriorating underneath you
and she's told you point blank i'm not
leaving
and so in a way she is separating from
you by staying put
and at some point you've got to just
take care of what you can take care of
which is you
and i would i mean dave you can feel
free to say but
i'd get a one bedroom apartment and say
this is where i'm gonna move
and i hope you will join me here and
this is where my money's gonna be
this is where our care is gonna be and
then at some point you
have to stop blaming every quote-unquote
mental health professional
in your area and that means they're
probably telling you guys some stuff
y'all didn't feel like hearing
but you're gonna have to go get some
some help on your own whether it's from
a good pastor or
from a counselor in your area and you
gotta start working on you man
but at some point the fantasy of this
thing's just gonna roll back out and
it's all gonna be good
your wife's choosing to live with her
friend and his husband
or her husband over you and that's just
the reality of it and at some point
you've gotta
kill that fantasy and start living in
the reality of you're gonna have to make
some plans and decisions
you need to sit down with a marriage
counselor to guide you through
how to um phrase this in a way that is
is hopefully healing and hopefully would
lead her to
go with you uh but you need to leave
yeah because let me just tell you let me
tell you what i heard
okay my wife would live with these
people
the rest of our lives i heard you say
that
now that's either drum overdramatization
hyperbole
or just weird yeah just straight up
strange so something's gotta get or
she's done with you yeah and she's not
gonna make it that may be the message
right that may be the message and i
don't know you've got two
two guys in this country more high on
marriage than dave ramsey
we both are high high on marriage but
this is a situation that you've
you've got to start protecting yourself
and um
she's got y'all got to get out of that
situation sorry zach solar panel
really hey man this is the dave ramsey
show
[Music]
cliff and i joined christian healthcare
ministries because we really liked the
concept of
christians sharing each other's burdens
and we really experienced that firsthand
when cliff
was diagnosed with heart disease it was
just such
a relief to know that financial burden
was going to be taken care of
chm is the original and longest serving
health cost sharing ministry
get started today and check us out at
chministries.org
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today
i am dave ramsey your host in the lobby
of ramsey solutions
on the debt free stage daniel and laurie
are with us hey guys how are you
better than we deserve i love it where
do you guys live dayton tennessee
oh yeah very fun ray county huh that's
right all right well good to have you
guys
welcome and how much debt have you two
paid off
we paid off 257 000 wow how long did
that take
it's a long it was a long time coming
but um
two years and three months two years and
three months and your range of income
during that two years
we make about 110 000 in our salaries
and with our airbnb
and extra jobs we made about 30 000 on
top of that each year
okay very cool what do you guys do for a
living we're both professors i'm a
business professor
and and i'm a math professor i teach
online and stay home with the kids
yeah what's the name of the school there
i've forgotten bryan college brian
yeah yeah a classic yeah a lot of
history
there it is yeah very cool yeah very
neat so
257 thousand is that your home
that these are homeless i'm looking here
with some people thank you we're weird
weird professors i love it i was gonna
say i know professors and
they're not pulling in 257 thousand
dollars so you almost have worked for a
season right
well this is really like 15 years we've
been working towards this
so buying selling houses we moved up
here from orlando so it helped to
go from that real estate market to here
paid cash for a house
bought a dream lot on the lake built a
dream home
on the lake sold the house that we owned
outright used that to pay down the
mortgage and then it worked
a lot yeah um and so you're living on
the lake we are living on the lake yep
was that nikki jack
it's chickamauga chickamauga yeah okay
all right yeah
beautiful area oh i'm so jealous that's
so neat you guys
look at that beautiful dream we are
yeah that's fun so what started you on
this journey two
years and three months ago well that is
when we started building the house
okay um the dream home so that's what we
just paid off um but we have been your
fans for 20 years
we've talked to you on the air a couple
times you sent us you gave us um
tickets to a live event in orlando our
son has done foundations of personal
finance
and wow we're just your fans and we've
lived your way
basically our whole marriage yes well
that's that's fair because we are fans
of you guys yeah well thank you that's
what we're doing
hold on though you're a business
professor you're way smarter than all of
this right
oh that's you you know all the things
and all the yeah you're overestimating
the intelligence of business
you said it not me all right i know a
math professor could get it because you
can do math
right that's easy but yeah i was more of
the nerd i liked the spreadsheets and i
would put the money you know i we had
this thermometer thing i would fill it
in
every month and it was just so exciting
to see and um
how much of this do you guys share in
your classrooms
of your life i get to share it fairly
often i actually teach a personal
finance class
and i get to share um some of my
milestones it's nice to
to be able to share that in the
classroom
in math classes i haven't really shared
it that's okay you don't have to i'm
just curious
just curious that's interesting very
well done you guys
how does it feel to have no payments in
the world
it's amazing yeah it's um it's like
atlas took the globe off
and i was just walking around now it
feels wonderful yeah like it gives us
it leaves us free to do things fun
things but also
um so we have an airbnb it leaves us
free to
bless other people with that without
thinking that we need the income from it
so
a couple families even we did this at
the very last day of 2020.
so even a couple of families in 2021
have needed a place to stay and we were
able to say we have a place
without we didn't we didn't need the
money it's very freeing wow that's so
neat
yeah you guys are amazing so proud of
you
thank you well done well done how old
are you two
i'm 44 and she's like 20 years younger
than yeah yeah she's
41. and you mentioned you got little
ones at home who you got at home yeah
not so little anymore our son zane is 16
and our daughter sophia is 13.
oh man look at you guys so well done
so uh what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is
regulating your lifestyle just dialing
it down making choices
being purposeful yeah and i was going to
say the same spending your money on
purpose deciding what's important to you
we like we shop at goodwill and our cars
are
super old and we have you know old
phones and we eat um
gum by the half stick to make them last
these things aren't important to us yeah
that's silly um but we'll also drop 100
on pizzas for the church youth group
because that's important to us so we
decide what we want to spend our money
on
and and do that yeah yeah so you're not
just completely cheapskate
you're cheapskate with a purpose yeah
yeah that's right i like it that live
like no one else so later we can live
and
give that's right like no one else two
or three pieces of generosity already in
this story
yeah so obviously you're living with an
open hand i'm so proud of you well god
has blessed
us and and now we get to use his
blessings even more
for him and for others so that is so
powerful
so well done well done well done well
done
just i'm i'm a nerd too so
february that's right so february 1
rolls over
you got out your budget to pay your
bills
and you all had to exhale for a second
because there was no mortgage to send
right what is that you said atlas took
the globe off
i i drilled that down for me what did
that feel like
well and for the first time we're like
you know we could we've never taken our
family
snow skiing like as a family we've like
hung out at a friend's house and done a
little snow skiing but we're like
hey we could drop a thousand dollars and
go snow skiing
like we've never even thought about
something like that before it's like
because that was less than our mortgage
payment you know right yeah so
we'd really like every month right just
from here
yes we're starting to think about just
doing things differently now yeah
getting a better car yeah yeah maybe the
cars are so expensive yeah we're still
like
that's not really important yeah that's
not really important to us so we'll run
them into the ground there's only two
hundred thousand miles on my toyota it's
good for another
200 hours everything's just getting
started
i love it man how exciting you guys are
so fun
i'm so proud of you we've got a copy of
chris hogan's book for you everyday
millionaires awesome and there's no
question that that's the uh the
direction you're going what's this house
worth
low fours mid-four maybe yeah yeah yeah
maybe five
yeah look at you oh you're so that's so
great well
done all right daniel and laurie we are
big fans of you guys
chattanooga tennessee area actually ray
county we need to be specific here yeah
dayton tennessee 257 000 paid off in
two years and three months making 110 up
to 140 with all the side hustles
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
three two one
[Applause]
ah that's so cool i love it
never gets old i love it now you know
the history on
that whole thing no so bryan college if
i remember correctly
i maybe get corrected on twitter because
i always do but if i remember this
william jennings brian
okay who was the famous orator and
barrister attorney in the scope's monkey
trial
ah okay that was all held in dayton
tennessee ray county thus
bryan college ends up being there i'm
pretty sure that's the origin of bryan
college is that right
i'm getting thumbs up from them yeah
look at that look at me with my
tennessee history
i love it yeah it's very very
interesting yeah ray county is a
beautiful area too well yeah
it's really i mean it's picturesque and
so their their their lake house is
let's just say so if you're listening to
this in california new york you
you should be salivating 400 000 lake
house think 10 million dollars right
that area is so beautiful yeah
so wonderful well like you said they
moved from orlando and they get
lot the quality real estate prices are
less
yeah yeah it's a great deal great deal
and a fabulous area to live and raise a
family
i mean it's just it's that's that's good
that's god's country right there man
and i'm thinking of that moment that you
know you're excited you paid the last
payment everybody's excite you know
you're high-fiving each other hugging
all that the kids are in they have that
little pomeranian dog running around yep
and it's all good
but it's not real until you sit down
that next month to pay your bills
and then you go oh that much money is in
the account
yeah it's not going to double what do
you want to do
and it's like let's go find the most
powerful wealth building tool
it turns out is my income and then you
think
it's just going to come next month and
then the month after that that's so
great
yeah that's so cool man what neat people
that's all such a powerful story
very well done you guys very well done
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at eight eight two five
five two two five cam is with us cam's
in jackson mississippi hi cam how are
you
hey pretty good and kind of out in the
out in the rural area south of jackson
mississippi but that's okay and i do
appreciate the opportunity being on the
show and posing the
situation and uh with uh with a possible
blessing that we're going the right way
okay how can i help yeah dave what
uh my wife and i she's the she's the big
money person
and what i mean by that she handles
everything i'm not not much on that but
but anyway we've had her home place for
years
and have always wanted to have something
over there about two years ago
we we bought a little 700 square foot
1948 house from the county
moved it over there did a lot of work
went to to get it completely remodeled
and
built back up and everything and of
course around
this rural area all the best builders
they are but they want to be paid every
week
so construction loan was out of the way
out of the way our house was paid off we
used a heloc to do
it got approved for a certain amount
because we used
other monies we did not and have not
used the whole he-lock and won't
but i always wanted this little place to
stand on its own debt
and so it's sitting there basically free
and clear
uh the heloc is the only debt we got how
much is the heat lock
it was we got approved for 150 how much
you owe 90 yeah we just we
just got through with everything 90 000
on a 700 square foot house
well we have built the thing for old age
and now did you add 10 000 square feet
to it
no how do you spend 90 000
on 700 feet well when you
when you're starting from square one now
we've now we had to add
yeah because it was 700 we had no
utility room
we had none of none of the amenities to
it so we had to build on to it
so what is this total problem
and the land worth nowadays
we're it's probably looking to be about
a hundred and eighty thousand
with the acreage it's got and what's the
acreage worth
acreage by itself yeah probably
sixty okay
all right um so you have a hundred and
uh
a hundred and uh eighty thousand dollar
property that is paid for and you owe
ninety thousand
extra on your home and what is your
first mortgage balance
our first mortgage we don't we didn't
have a mortgage okay so nothing had a
mortgage except the only mortgage you
have is this ninety thousand dollar
heloc
yes yeah okay and so it's sitting at
about seven
it's sitting at seven point five percent
yeah
everything we're trying to do with this
little house and all the
the bank different banks i've talked to
and credit unions and stuff
the best we're going to be able to do is
a cash out on it
at about 3.7 our thought is to do that
put it all toward the heloc whatever
little remaining balance is there
we'll pay that but then make sure we've
got this little house
holding its own debt at seven five why
does that need to hold its own debt it's
your debt
why does it have to be on that house
where can it be on your i don't want it
i want it on i don't i really don't want
it on my primary
house why does it matter because the
interest rate's higher
it's not higher on your personal home on
the heloc we're going to get rid of the
heloc and get you a first mortgage on
your personal residence
uh what'd you say your household income
is
our household income is about 120. okay
so what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna put 90
000
on five years fixed rate no closing
costs
on your home at the credit union at 2.9
no closing cost fixed rate five years
at 2.9 or less credit union won't do
that go to a different credit union go
to your local bank somebody will do that
deal
because you got tons of equity in both
properties leave the little house
standing free and clear it doesn't
matter which mortgage the house is on
because you're going to pay it off in
very short order anyway if you're smart
matter of fact you ought to be debt-free
in two years yeah
and you could just do that you could
just pay it off in two years
yeah and but i just i guess i'm fixated
on this interest rate well don't it to
something lower you could be fixated on
90 000 going away
got you yeah yeah and that's true and we
are 45 a year for two years
90. done but
but doing a first mortgage versus what
we're trying to do on this little
if you want to get a lower interest rate
during that two years
on a five year like note like i just
said do it on your personal residence
because you're going to get a lower
a lower rate than you're going to get on
a non-owner occupied because that's why
it's 375 because it's not occupied
yeah right it's a secondary property and
you can get your local credit union to
do that
but listen here run the numbers on this
okay the difference in seven
and three let's say 2.9 is
four percent on ninety thousand oh wait
we don't have ninety thousand we have 45
after a year
oh wait so the you're really only paying
just a handful of dollars to keep the
heloc in place
if you get your button gear and get this
paid off in two years
and so the actual nominal dollars that
the interest rate is creating the real
dollar amount
is not enough to buy a biscuit hardly
and it sounds like
the uh this the need to get this new
property
overrode this good chance i am
debt free and now that we went and did
it it's not making anybody feel any
better
and now we realize we owe somebody 90
thousand dollars and we had everything
free and clear before we did that
yeah i'm just trying to do this a minute
so what we're discussing here is
you refinancing this you might save
eighteen hundred dollars
if you pay it off in two years it's an
eighteen hundred dollar problem we're
discussing
and that's not worth the anxiety you're
feeling over it now yeah so
if you want to if you wanted to
refinance it on a five-year fixed rate
three percent are under no closing costs
no closing costs
must be fixed rate no balloon fully
amortizing on five years no prepayment
penalty with your credit union they'll
do that deal
you mean you have to lean on them but
they'll do that deal that's a good deal
for them
and they portfolio that loan they hold
it in their portfolio
that loan will work and that will save
you 1800
over two years approximately maybe
closer to two thousand
and that's worth a trip to the bank
right it's probably worth doing but it's
not your problem
right you're you know i think you use
the right word fixated
on the interest rate you're fixated on
the wrong thing be fixated on
kicking 90 grand but and getting it out
of your life
and next time you start a project like
this begin with the end in mind
because you have way overdone the little
house
well i'm way overdone more so dave you
mortgaged your home
your mortgage the place where your
family lives for a
700 square foot overdone
yeah did you spend 90 grand i mean run
that out that's a thousand dollars a
square foot
yeah we just spent on these things
golden baseboards oh my god it's you
know
yeah you can you can do a lot in
southern mississippi for a thousand
dollars a foot
i tell you what man you can buy most of
southern mississippi
uh yeah they go a long way so yeah cam
that's
um anyway begin with the end in mind on
projects
set better budgets on them they give you
more reasonable returns
uh but you you know whatever mess you've
made here certainly can be cleaned up
and the fastest way to fix this is to
pay it off the fastest way possible
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two
five you guys jump in we'll talk about
your life and your money so
let me back up what would i have done
if i woke up in issues i got mama's old
home place over here
i want to put a place on it i make 120
a year our current residence has no
mortgage
what do we do you save up and you pay
cash that's right for whatever you're
going to do
number one and you could have done the
exact same deal in two years
yep that's paying this off in two years
and then you
paid cash as you went now here's what
will happen when you pay cash instead of
a loan
you don't spend ninety thousand dollars
on a 700 square foot the weirdest thing
when you're spending your own money
instead of borrowed money
you're more careful with it because
suddenly you feel like we got 150 to
spend on this project
right yeah instead of hey we need to get
this we want to have our vision for this
and we're going to do it
we're going to see that vision all the
way through i mean when you write the
check out of the heloc
you don't feel it's not real money it's
not real money when you write your check
out of your savings that you pounded to
put in there for two years
you're like i don't think we need the
golden bay sports that's right let's
just go with wood
it changes the whole thing oh man
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the dave ramsey show you can
be intentional about your character
you can have money and a career you
are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios
it's the dave ramsey show where debt is
dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host dr john deloney ramsey
personality and best-selling author is
my co-host today
open phones at
five that's 825-5225 eight eight two
five five
two two five stephanie is in chesapeake
virginia hi stephanie welcome to the
dave ramsey show
hi thank you how are you guys doing
today better than we deserve what's up
um
so several years ago my husband left um
left a job and had an hour there and
when he left
he took the ira but at the time he moved
it into
an ira savings account so it's just it's
not even
ira it's just a holding account he's
never moved it back to
anything else so it's still sitting
there and getting like two dollars a
year
um we're in baby step two
still and um i know when you get the
babysit before you invest
back into that should we move that into
an ira actually right now or just
leaving and leave it in the holding
account until we get to baby step four
now you can go ahead and roll it um just
get with a smart vester pro click smart
vester at daveramsey.com
and tell them you have an ira you need
to do a rollover on
and you'll just roll it into the types
of mutual funds we talk about growth
growth and income
aggressive growth and international
spread it across those four
sit down with that smartvestor pro and
understand what you're doing
but there's no taxes and immediately
that money will start working much
harder
than it is working then when you get to
baby step four and you start saving 15
of your income in retirement you'll
either start opening roth iras at that
point
um or you'll be doing you know the
retirement plan at work a 401 k or a 403
b
or something along those lines you
technically can't add
to a rollover ira
okay so you won't you won't like pick up
where that account left off it's just
going to sit there and do its own thing
okay okay okay that's that's all
you know it's been sitting in there for
several years and you know
it's just doing nothing and you might as
well get it doing something even if it's
a small amount of money
so every week i feel like i am taking
the role of another caller on this show
but
i just heard something i've never heard
before explain to me an iri savings
account
it's a bad uh okay an ira is
not um
an investment it is the way an
investment is treated
okay so we suggest inside
it's a coat like a winter coat that
wraps around
an investment and keeps it warm from
taxes okay okay
so what is in that coat can be mutual
funds
which is what we suggest or you can do
stupid it can be all gamestop stocks it
could be
well you'd be difficult to do that but
you actually could be that stupid
and i mean you have to be a
self-directed ira to get that far but
you can
open an ira at a bank right and what's
inside the code
is a simple bank savings account at one
percent ah
okay translation sucks right dumb
well i mean it's not it's you're not
dumb for doing it but it's a dumb thing
to do right
because it's obviously paying no no
money and so you don't
buy um you don't get your transmission
fixed at the muffler store okay
so you don't buy investments at the bank
love it ever all right ever because they
know how to do one thing
get you in debt actually two things and
run your checking account for you there
you go
that's all they know how to do but that
you know so you
some banks have investment divisions or
departments or whatever
but by and large they're not in good
okay so you're much better off to go to
an investment professional like a
smartvestor pro
and sit down and get your transmission
fixed at the transmission fix
store gotcha and um you don't by the way
you don't go to smart investor pros to
do other stuff you don't go over there
to get i don't know
um you get your tires put right now you
know you don't you just don't
you know however far will stretch the
freaking metaphor but but the uh uh but
don't you know
use the thing for what it's for okay and
when you when you start messing that up
that's
so another example of that is when
insurance people
start doing retirement planning yep
a hundred percent of the time that's a
bad idea because that just
yeah that's a product for them because
here's what happens they act like
they're a financial planner they act
like they're an investment broker in the
way they conduct themselves
the vernacular that they use but the
actual product that they're selling you
is cash value life insurance sucks
beyond belief right
or worse than that some kind of an
annuity product okay when you don't need
any of that in your retirement investing
you need just good mutual funds inside
your roth ira or your 401k
it's really it's very clean simple low
fee and
low transaction costs all that kind of
stuff compared to insurance
so when you're buying it you don't buy
your investments from insurance people
you know and so don't don't mix the
transmission don't get the transmission
fixed to the muffler
and it just keeps you moving in the
right direction so that's all she did
they just went over at their bank and
did
an ira rollover but what was inside the
coat
keeping it warm was a tiny little
savings account so so that bank made a
whole bunch of money on their money that
they didn't see
i mean just like they do every time we
park money in a bank for one percent
you know it's like you that's why you
don't put a hundred thousand bucks in
there and have it sitting there at one
percent
right okay because what are they doing
they're loaning it back out people on
credit cards at eighteen they're making
that that's how banks are
you know they're making a 8 10 car loan
yeah
and paying you one or three quarters of
one percent
on your money and to borrow your money
from you then they loan it back out
and make money on it now you're loaning
the bank money is what you're doing when
you have a savings account and if you
have an ira savings account you've
effectively locked your money up right
yeah yeah you've loaned it to them for a
long time at least until you wake up and
roll it over right
so you can always roll it over and get
out of it but you don't have to stay
in a bad ira you can roll it to a good
ira but it's just moving the coat
um and keeping something much more high
quality warm
than something low quality warm i love
it frank is with us in philadelphia
hi frank welcome to the dave ramsey show
okay sure yeah you doing it uh good man
how can
dr john and i help
uh yes uh so so um i am a recent
college graduate i graduated about a
month ago
um congratulations man sixty thousand
dollars for debt
thank you thank you uh so i graduated uh
and
but i graduated with sixty thousand
dollars in debt uh and i also
uh i'm i'm also a lucky homeowner
um uh i don't pay mortgages i don't
i just pay taxes at the end of the year
but the house is worth 47 000
um but um due to the corona virus i
wasn't
uh i actually lost my job so now i'm
unemployed and it's like
you know i got a 60 000 debt to pay off
soon um and i
live in the house i can't really pay
bills i can't really do anything like
that
so what's your what's your degree in
france
uh is in israeli communications in
communications
okay and you got a four-year degree from
a college in communications
excellent well done sir that's awesome
well done well you're you're in a
troubled
market in uh philadelphia right now with
corona shutdown
very difficult to move around in philly
much less get employed
and those kinds of things but we'll try
to come up with some ideas you hold on
through this break
and john and i'll come back we'll see if
we can guide you on some ideas
this is the dave ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers to recommend
blinds.com is no exception they offer
high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters
with easy online ordering free shipping
and a guaranteed perfect fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
[Music]
all right we're talking to frank in
philadelphia he's got a paid for 45
000 house no job but just graduated
lost his job but just graduated with a
four-year degree in
communications we got to get him some
income coming in john what do you think
that's right so frank what is it that
you want to do man
did i push the button let me try this
now try it again frank there you go
sorry
what is it you want to do what do you
want to do man
uh i aim to be a video defending
photographer uh
uh in the future that's my treat that's
my passion okay i plan on doing it in uh
near what kind of photographer
uh uh
so why do you need a four-year degree to
be a photographer
uh it's not a uh it was kind of a
decision that i made
when i was younger i got back into
school uh
when i was 25 i'm like i'm not a
traditional student i'm 29 now
so uh i got back into school when i was
about 25 or 24
so uh so i wasn't really thinking
through but like now that i hey
i completed my degree it's like i'm
finding out like i i really didn't need
it to become a photographer or
videographer
you know so have you ever been paid to
take pictures
yes yes by who
as a co was a customer or were you
working for somebody
yeah so i'm going to ask
a question i'm going to ask this
question not to be disrespectful but
just to get an honest assessment of
where you're at are you good at it
or is it something that you just like to
do
yes i'm great i'm greed okay so
i you got two two things going on here
number one
you're gonna have to join the the ranks
of millions right now
who are putting together two and three
jobs you're stringing it together you
gotta hit the streets man and start
hustling
and that might be working a shift at
home depot
and then getting um driving uber at
night you gotta go get a job
you got a four-year degree so i think
you can even do better than that or go
into a management position and then what
you're gonna have to start doing
is figuring out ways to market yourself
put yourself out there where you can
take pictures whether that's on
instagram or
youtube or get next to some folks
weddings or whatever the thing is in
philadelphia that will even allow you
right now to go take photos
and start getting your work out there
but just to sit at home
and wait to be able to work
full-time as a as a photographer from
the floor up
man that's a tall ass so you got to get
some income coming in quick
yeah you need the photography gig needs
to start as a side hustle to your main
gig
and your main gig is making money to eat
that's right
and pay those that 60 grand off so you
can be a side hustle
so on your photography business so that
you can grow it enough that you quit the
main gig
that's right and our and our friend ken
coleman in this proximity principle book
here's the thing you're going to go work
let's say home depot you'll get a job
there
every person that you hear that's got a
wedding you're
you're going to be on their front door
with a with a card you're going to be
talking to them in the
in the aisles anybody who's got a kid
who's about to be born anybody's got
graduations you're going to be hitting
those folks up and you're going to
slowly build your circle that way or
start working for a wedding planner
setting up chairs
yep and oh by the way you're going to be
around weddings
and then you might get to take some
pictures at a wedding who knows
there will be a day when that wedding
photographer doesn't show up it's going
to be too cold or too hot or too snowy
and you're going to have your
gear ready to rock and roll and you're
going to save the day and their car
broke down and superman was there
setting up chairs
oh that's exactly right clark kent
that's exactly right
you get in proximity that's what ken
talks about so we're going to send you a
copy of ken's book the proximity
principle but you need to get in the
proximity of people who need photography
even if you're setting up the chairs and
get in there and just
but and bust it man and john's right the
first thing you gotta do is get the wolf
away from your door cause he's howling i
heard him on the phone
yeah and we got to get him away you got
to get the dead gun bills paid and get
the pressure off and the stress off of
you
and that's just the primary reason for
making an income
is existence right the secondary reason
for making an income of
self-actualization
and doing what we love and so uh we
don't we don't sacrifice
existence in order to self-actualize
that doesn't it's backwards that's not
how that works
so you hang on kelly i'll pick up we'll
get you a copy of ken coleman's book
the proximity principle and get out
there and john's right and stir it up
man
stir it up leanne's in charleston west
virginia hey leanne how are you
hey dave i'm fine how are you better
than i deserve what's up
well um i grew up listening to your show
my parents were avid listeners they
completed every step of their plan
and then they started me and my husband
out on it when we first got married
wow and now we've been married yeah 13
years
and our only debt is the remaining 100
000
on our mortgage good um yeah back in
september
my parents both passed away in a plane
crash
i'm sorry please thank you um we've
inherited
uh 360 thousand dollars just from the
life insurance in the estate and then
another
300 000 uh three yeah 300 000 from my
dad's 401k
um i really want to honor my parents and
how i manage
the inheritance good for you and so
here's my
thank you so here's my question um we
would like to move into a bigger space
but um how do we decide how much house
we can afford in a situation like this
our idea has been to buy
a new home with cash and then um
and then sell off the current one and
use that money to pay off the remaining
mortgage um but i just i don't
really okay what is your current home
worth i don't really know
i we got it for 145 i think it's worth
more now with the market going up
what do you think it's worth today what
are you going to sell it for oh
i think at least 160. okay and what are
you talking about moving to what kind of
price range home are you moving into
well that's what we're not really sure
about we've been looking what are you
thinking about
but also not a million 250 but
no i mean entertaining the idea of
350 but i feel like that's overkill
and obviously what's your household
income have to offer
my husband's a pastor and he makes about
uh
57 000 a year
and you're stay-at-home mom yeah
okay all right yeah i think 300 is good
budget i don't mind that
you got 300 that's not in the ira right
yeah and you're going to pay cash for it
and then we're going to sell the other
house
is it is would it be better to pay off
the current one and then go hell
shopping
but then we have a smaller smaller
budget to work with no you got your 300
in cash sitting there right now from the
life insurance right
yeah yeah you pay cash for it and then
sell your house okay
and you're gonna have a little bit of
equity out of your house that you can
invest and do other things with and
you've got the inherited ira to invest
into other things with
you paid cash and you're 100 debt free i
think your dad's smiling
uh it just feels kind of crazy to go out
and spend all that in the house
um so what what is it about 250. yeah i
hear the hesitancy
do you not feel like you're worth 300
what's what's the hesitancy there
i don't i don't know they never lived
like that you know
yeah yeah but you're not talking about
that you're talking about talking about
you and your and your husband
what is it about that number i don't
know it's i mean he's a pastor he
doesn't
you know i don't it just feels oh it's
not it's not extravagant
it's not extravagant and it's not gross
if you told me 750 i would tell you that
was extravagant and gross
yeah well i don't want to go into that i
know you wouldn't be in debt if we
cashed out everything you could do that
but
i just don't think you ought to do that
in your case your situation will be
that you will have about 40 of your then
net worth
in your home and you're 100 debt free
that's not a bad ratio
and then everything that was going
towards the mortgage
is going to be used to build wealth and
to be generous with
continue to build continue to build the
nest egg continue the legacy that your
parents started
and that you're just working off of the
platform that they created
yeah and you'll be millionaires and and
be patient
and be pastors and that's there's
nothing wrong with that you didn't do
anything wrong you weren't gross you
weren't greedy
you aren't showing off you're not out of
control
and there will be a number of people i
would tell you if you were you know that
right
yeah i know i'm not gonna lie to you i'm
telling you the truth
i mean i'll call you out if i thought
you were doing it because i i
i love your listen your primary filter
on this
is is this honoring to mom and dad's
memory
my answer is yes you're paying cash
and it's a reasonable ratio yes this is
the dave ramsey show
[Music]
you know healthcare has gotten to be
ridiculous it puts people
um you know on the brink and so it would
have put us on the brink
had we not had chm chm saved our life
same time financial lives christian
healthcare ministries or chm
is not health insurance but it is a
budget-friendly option
and the original health cost sharing
ministry for christians
learn more today and check us out at
chministries.org
that's chministries.org
[Music]
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee meaning if you
mismeasure you pick the wrong color
you'll remake your window blinds for
free you get free samples free shipping
when the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use the promo code
ramsey
to get the best possible deal
all right today's question comes from
nicholas in new york
nicholas asks how do i say no to friends
and family
that want to go out and do things that
just do not fit in my budget
i'm currently on baby step 2 and i'm
doing the debt snowball and my budget is
very tight
i just always feel terrible saying no to
my friends and i'm afraid to lose them
any thoughts i think you're under 40.
yeah i think so i was gonna say i think
so um
nicholas i'm just gonna call out the
elephant in the room here
if your friends don't want to hang out
with you
then you need to get some other friends
they're not friends they're not your
friends
friends that you have to pay for is
called prostitution that's i wasn't
going to go there but dave did so yes
nicholas these aren't your friends so to
put it in perspective
um when me and my friends this is just
five six seven years ago
we got together and we were all trying
to
tighten up things financially and so we
had fun at the house bringing leftovers
over
and you know there would be quarter
bottle wine and a half
two liter bottle of diet coke and a half
eaten casserole and we didn't care we
called it rotisserie we just rotated
friend's house here's the deal we made
it work
why those are my closest friends in the
world
and friends who say oh you have a goal
you're trying to better your life and we
don't want you around
then uh sucks to be you man we're going
out without you are sending you
very clear signals that they're not your
friend so how do you say no
i hate to tell you this but you say no
and then you have to do the hard work of
trying to find some other friends man
yeah if
um your friendship is based on the
activity of hanging out
it is not a real friendship right and so
you've got some work to do on
how to build actual friends yeah um
because you you know i feel
terrible saying no to my friends at 60
years old
also but not for those reasons it's it's
if a friend of mine
you know has something going on and i
really should be there but i can't
because i've got something else
right i can't be present but it's not uh
uh
and so i feel bad if i can't be there uh
one of my friend's mom passed away i
couldn't get to the funeral
you know i was in the middle of
something else i couldn't go
and i felt terrible for that but that
that's a different kind of a thing then
i don't have the money to go
spend money because the only way my
friends want to hang out with me is when
we're spending money at some club
in an example in my life very similar is
i had a buddy called the other day
with a great real estate opportunity
said hey me
and another friend of ours we're getting
in on this we want you to pitch in
and it wasn't a part of my plan for 2021
or 2022
and i'd said or ever well i mean i
wouldn't mind
but but here's the thing i told him
i can't be in on this one and he said
well you're an idiot and then we talked
about our kids
right he's still my close friend right
and so that's the difference between
is he gonna love you plus your values
not
um walk away from you yeah that sucks
man yeah
there's a uh reading your sentence
structure
and the way you went at the question
tells me that there's a shallowness
to uh your connectivity to these people
you call friends
yep and so let's deepen the connectivity
so let's get a
few of them that are real friends and
fewer hangers on
there you yeah yeah that deal hey folks
if you're like me
drive time is podcast time and if you
listen to podcast you're going to love
this the brand new ramsey network
app is like a podcast player with all of
our shows
in one place so you can get the dr john
delony show you can get the anthony
o'neil the table with anthony o'neill
show
the dave ramsey show the chris hogan
show the rachel cruz show the ken
coleman show christy wright show
entree leadership the call of the day
podcast all in one place and you can
browse by topic
you can save your favorite clip and you
can share them with your friends
and you can get better in every single
area of your life to money to career to
business to leadership
it's all there mental health even never
again
should you struggle to find the
education the empowerment you need to
improve your life download our ramsey
network
app in the app store just search
for ramsey network
yep one more way you can get dr john
doloni you know what the world needs man
i'll tell you what ryan is with us
ryan's in san antonio hey ryan how are
you
i'm doing all right you sir better than
i deserve what's up
uh i'm not sure if y'all are who i need
to talk to but i just
i'm 60 years old and didn't do any good
planning in my
earlier years and getting to the point
where i don't know that i can keep on
keeping on and i was just
needing somebody to talk to and i
thought maybe y'all could line me up
with somebody
well man i appreciate your trust um
tell me what's going on i
just getting old and tired and
hurt all the time it's just hard to go
to work every day what do you do i said
i do
uh i work maintenance
okay where do you work maintenance what
type of facility uh
it's a state uh it's a state park
okay wow how long you been doing that
um going on nine years now okay
all right so i can hear in your voice
you things are heavy man
well it's just talking on the radio like
this is kind of stressful oh
of course yeah yeah
i feel it man so why when you say you're
tired
that means a lot what do you mean i just
i don't
physically i just don't get any rest and
it's hard to get up and get going and
just
i hurt all the time i mean this is not
stuff y'all
i mean the financial part is i didn't
plan good
so yeah i don't have a whole lot to fall
back on
so what do you make what kind of income
uh
i think gross about 40 000. cool are you
married
no okay was once a long time ago okay
sounds like that you can fix anything to
me
okay can you
uh if i called you up and said hey my
dishwasher's out i need you to come
check it and
change it out for me could you do that
yeah but it would probably take me twice
as long as a lot of folks
why because of the physical no because
i i i have a lot of knowledge in
a lot of areas a little knowledge in a
lot of areas
and i can get things done i've worked
with enough people to know there's a
whole lot of people who have a whole lot
more skills than i do
[Music]
so let me ask you this are you i'm go
ahead i'm going to
no you go ahead i i think well let me
tell you what's running through my head
okay um i know a guy that is a handyman
for a living has a little business
called handyman
and he goes and just does miscellaneous
stuff for people in their homes
and even small offices and that kind of
stuff and he'll show up at your
lake house and fix your whatever put
that gutter back up or make sure it gets
put up or
get get a little subcontractor if he
needs some help and um
and you know he's making like a hundred
a year but he can fix
anything or figure out how to fix it and
um
and he doesn't overcharge and he always
shows up on time and does what he says
he's going to do
but uh it's so freaking dependable it's
unbelievable
i i got the last part covered about the
independable
and i'm not a people person
i don't you know i work where there's a
lot of people but i'm not
so here's the thing ryan my guess is you
talked to
my friend ryan from san antonio in a
voice
that if you heard somebody talking to a
woman at a grocery store
you probably knock their teeth out the
back of your head
because when dave ramsey compliments you
your first thought is to deflect it you
know i'm thinking of you right now
i'm thinking of what covet has been for
millions of people
and state parks have been a place where
people could go be humans
and they could go get together i could
get my kids together and we could go
outside and see other people
and wave and see pets and see dogs and
all those things
and you just slump your shoulders and
see i'm just doing this
and so and still until you start
treating ryan
with the dignity and respect he deserves
you're not going to be able to hear
compliments you're not going to look in
the mirror
and be proud you're not going to be able
to go see a doctor and get your physical
stuff taken care of you're not gonna be
able to go
have the humility to see a counselor and
get the help you need there
but i want today be to the day you start
talking to ryan
and hang on i'll tell you what we're
gonna hook you up with our career guy
ken coleman yep
and see if he can't give you some
guidance in helping you move to the next
stage on your career
because you do need a new career you're
physically tired of it
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at 825-5225 michael is in
sacramento hey michael welcome to the
dave ramsey show
[Music]
hi dave um i've just got such a
predicament i've i'm 54 years old
i've got um my primary residence
i've got so much credit debt i've got
about 10
000 credit card debt but i probably have
about 300 000
dollars total in non-mortgage debt
and i just feel like i'm spinning my
wheels and i don't know what to attack
first
i just i just feel lost what is the um
what is the other 290 000
the other 290 000 is between student
loans
uh lines of credit uh loans
that i had to take um when i got
divorced about
12 years ago to um i had a house that
we were going to it was we were trying
to sell and i
told the bank that if you let me sell
this and not go to foreclosure
i will take on that loan as a personal
debt because
i pay my bills so i did that and i've
been
paying on that ever since so um and then
a variety of other ones how much is that
um
that loan is fifty thousand dollars at
four percent okay
and how much is the student loan cars
that student loan is uh
sixty seven thousand and the cars are
what
the cars total uh
ninety yeah ninety thousand
two cars and what's your household
income
uh 170 salary and then i just recently
had an opportunity which i started to
make an extra 3 500 a month
okay over time that's going to be
consistent excellent so 210. i have a
pension
and and what is your home worth my home
is worth uh
900 000 and i owe uh
sale 575 on it
what do you do for a living and i have
two round properties i'm a physician
assistant
okay and you have two rental properties
in that and what are they worth
uh let's see i have one in montana
that's worth uh
300 310 000 and i owe 230 000 on and i
have one in idaho
that's worth uh 325 000 and i owe
330 on it
and then i have a pension of 600 000
that i can have once i'm sewing 11 years
or i can take uh
that's lump sum where i can take 3 000 a
month annuity
okay so um
how much do you want to be out of this
mess really bad or just
or it's just sort of bothering you no
i've lived like this my entire life and
when i got divorced i mean i still
the other part are you ready to get your
life back
i i've been ready for a while because
you need to really be ready because i'm
getting ready to sell everything in your
life
i'm i'm ready i mean let's sell both
rental properties in both cars this week
so sell all three properties no the both
rental properties
and both cars yeah okay
all right get you two five thousand
dollar cars
you make 210 000 so
now you have now you have um
not you have your home and you will have
210 thousand dollars left minus so
you're gonna have about 150 000
left in debt and you make 210 and you're
going to pay that off in two years
the only problem is i just got these
properties six months or a few months
ago and out there on a
more exchange i don't care and i'm gonna
be taxed heavily
i don't care doesn't matter all right
your life sucks
you're drowning man yeah you have so
much crap in your life that is not
producing joy
well if i can tell you one more thing
i've got an alimony of 2 000 a month
that's never going to go away
until i die okay that's 24
000 out of 210 that doesn't keep us from
getting out of debt
right so 24 and 75 is 100
out of 210 you're gonna live on 210 and
you're going to be debt-free in two
years and you're going to sell
everything
except your personal residence okay so
if i listen
i'll tell you what i'm reacting to i'm
reacting to the tone of your voice when
you called in
you sounded so overwhelmed so despondent
so stuck
that it sounded to me like you were
willing to do almost anything
and that's where i am that's where i am
i think you should do
i think you should feel that way because
you feel like there's 12
freaking years this stuff's been hanging
around your neck and you make all this
money and you're a pa and you can't get
traction you are so freaking stuck it's
unbelievable
and you can't breathe and that's what i
heard did i miss something
nope you nailed it and every time you
walk into that hospital to help other
people you've got 14 cinderblocks in
your own backpack
is that fair yeah at least
brother you got to set that pack down
you got a bunch of crap in your life man
put it down man just stuff 90 000 worth
of cars
yeah jesus who who are you
who are you impressing man i know i'm
not asking that in a jerk way but
there's something in you that says i
need a million plus dollar house
and these well i mean he's in sacramento
yeah that's a three two and two
expensive cars and
two homes that something's telling you
that you're not good enough man
what is it yeah you know that this
didn't happen all at once
this has been you've this has been death
by a thousand cuts layer upon layer upon
layer this stuff is built up and then it
never goes away
so it's a cumulative effect i'll solve
it
12 years ago thing we got a student loan
that's still hanging around after all
these years
uh we then we go buy cars and now we
roll these houses into a 1031
so you're gonna get hammered on taxes
out the backside so you're gonna have
100 000 in taxes
probably yeah i'm gonna have a lot 15 of
what
what was your what do you think your
gain is that you rolled into these
my gain will probably uh because i put
uh
eighty thousand down on one and seventy
thousand down on the guess that's not
what you put down
has nothing to do with the calculation
of your gain how much capital gains did
you roll into this 1031.
i was i was told my taxes will be uh if
i were to cash out about fifty thousand
dollars okay good that's right
less than i thought that pretty good
it's only 50 grand
this is the price of cleaning up your
life
yes so i you know basically you're going
to get enough out of these properties to
pay your taxes and be free so that's a
wash we're gonna sell the cars for close
to a wash
and so now you have two hundred and ten
thousand dollars left
i was wrong earlier it's not 150 because
of the capital gains bill
i said 160 150 but it's going to be 210
i didn't have 50 000 capital gains bill
in there but now i do so
you're you're still you know so how fast
do you pay off 210 making 210
three years at 70 grand
okay and that means you have 200 it
means you have 110 000
to live on after you pay alimony and 70
grand towards debt for three years and
you're 100 debt free how old are you
54. you won't be debt free when you're
57 this is how you do it
okay i just want to make sure i
understand so both cars sell both rental
properties
and then hit your plan hard
nothing else complete focus
like i'm so pissed off i am so sick and
tired of being sick and tired
that i have not only sold this stuff i'm
gonna sell two of the kids if they don't
hide
i'm just gonna have to get my wife to
buy in hopefully i won't be too hard
yeah well i mean does she want her life
back ask her if she wants a husband that
can
sleep a full night of sleep can breathe
yeah a husband that can walk around the
neighborhood without his head spinning
without having to grab his phone every
two seconds
yeah they can wake up with a smile on
his face
we call it financial peace that's what
we call
it and you can do this man you can do it
but it's just a matter of if you want to
if you get sick and tired of being sick
and tired that's when you change your
life man if you can get through pa
school and if every day you can walk
into that traumatic situation and heal
people you can do this i know you can't
do it
just are you ready to be willing to go
because there's a completely different
groove we're going to plow down the
middle of your brain
yeah to get your brain to function
differently because you've been running
through you've been running the great
american mess
and if your wife can contribute to this
too you can get done even faster yeah we
yeah yeah so i mean the only thing i did
the only thing i did to her sell her
that's all i did and our montana house i
guess but oh well you're costing us the
idaho house dave but
oh well z yeah that's that whole mean
dave ramsey guy
hey man you can do it i believe in you
my chest is tight for
him man i felt it i feel it it was in
the air
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the dave ramsey show you can
be
intentional about your character you can
have money
and a career you are the hero in your
[Music]
story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the dave ramsey
show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host dr john deloney ramsey
personality
best-selling author is my co-host as we
take your calls
about well your life and your money so
dr john's here which means we talk about
your life in any way you want to having
to do with your
boundaries with your family or anything
going on mental health wise we're here
to help
and of course all the stuff about your
money and how those two things interact
is
somewhat hilarious so triple eight eight
two five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five five
two two five david is in tucson arizona
hi david how are you
hello david dr john i appreciate your
taking my call
our place i don't know if you've noticed
but uh some of your principles differ a
little bit from conventional advice
stop it dave
crazy i love it
my questions are about investment mix
yeah you talk about growth aggressive
growth
uh growth and income and international
and some of those aren't the
terms many others use so i was hoping
you could characterize those a little
for me but the big question is
it's all stock nothing else mixed with
it
how does that change related to age and
goals
and particularly as you're starting to
get closer to retirement
yeah really really good question and uh
you're right none of those things line
up with um
conventional uh wisdom it does mostly
it's about a 90 overlap but there's
enough uh nuanced
uh that i don't agree with with
traditional financial planning theory
that they all stay pissed off at me all
the time um
and write write nasty blogs and stuff
but anyway so let's go back to the first
question
an aggressive growth fund is also called
a small
cap cap means capitalization
in the financial world so a small
company
small company fund okay and that's your
your startup companies
uh your tech companies volatile
wild that's the aggressive growth stock
mutual fund okay
sometimes they call it an emerging
market fund
too okay so that's the aggressive the
international
obviously means overseas stocks or
foreign stocks
and sometimes you'll see it called that
it has a kissing cousin called a
uh a global fund and so if you think
about the whole globe
like he's got the whole world and his so
it's the globe okay
the whole globe right and so that means
it's got u.s stocks in it too
it's not just overseas or not just
international a pure international has
no u.s in it
no american companies in it and so the
global funds
typically outperform the international
funds because
american stocks typically outperform the
rest of the world by and large
as a whole okay now then a a
a growth fund is also called uh you know
it's just a middle of the road
an index fund an s p 500 fund would
qualify as a growth fund
but it's just a company that it's a it's
a mutual fund that has stocks in it that
are growing so it's kind of
mid-range mid-cap fund it's also called
the uh the growth and income will have a
few bonds in it a lot of times
but it's mainly huge companies uh so
sometimes called a blue chip
fund and or a large
cap fund the other end of the spectrum
from the small cap
so this is uh alcoa aluminum
general motors boring
most of the time compared to a little
startup company on the other end of the
spectrum that's going zoom zoom or not
and back and forth and very volatile and
all over the map so
that's the mix that we recommend then uh
and that's that's a question that's
the an answer that's great for the whole
audience to hear that's why i'm taking a
little extra time with it
then the uh the the second thing part of
your question is the the allocation
theory which is that as you get older
you should move from
equities or stock type mutual funds
towards
bonds and money markets to get safer and
safer as you move towards retirement and
that's the theory of financial planning
i don't agree with
and i'll give you my basis for my
disagreement okay
it's called common sense so here's the
thing
so if you get to retirement and you have
half a million million and a half in
your 401 k something like that
even 300 000 you're likely at 65
never going to touch the principal
you're going to only live off of the
income that it creates
you know unless you just want to drain
the account down now if you want to
drain the account down then you can
change your
allocations based on the fact that
you're going to use the money
but if you are 65 years old at
retirement and you are healthy
statistically the average death age of a
male in america
is 74 of a female is 76 right now
however if you make it to 65 and you're
healthy statistically you're going to
make it to 90.
so you have 25 freaking years
in order to outpace inflation and so if
you follow these
stupid allocation theory and you move
all your money into underperforming
items that are say quote unquote safer
then you're going to make no money for
25 years and inflation is going to kick
your butt
and so i'm 60 and i'm 100
invested in the four types i talked
about as far as the stock market goes
i don't have any bonds other than if
they sum in my growth and income
funds there might be some bonds in that
but i don't
i don't i don't buy bonds i don't have
i'm not moving towards stocks because
i'm decrepit and old at 60 years old
no i got 30 freaking years it's like
talking to a 30 year old and saying
oh be conservative because you're going
to be 60. it's the same 30 years
from 30 to 60 as it is from 60 to 90.
the only difference is is that everybody
freaks out and says oh my god you're
old so you have to get really super safe
now drop all of your performance
down to nothing and let inflation be
higher than the performance of your
portfolio
and kick your butt it's absolutely
asinine it's an asinine theory
but the financial planning communities
like a bunch of lemmings
sometimes they just follow each other
off the cliff whatever one of them says
do they all go do
and no one stops to question that the
emperor has no clothes except me
and then of course i have blogs written
because i said the emperor is butt naked
so uh it's a bad idea it's a bad idea
now if you've got
money that you want to access and you're
going to tear the principal down
in the next five years then yes get more
conservative and move out of equities
but if you're going to live off of the
goose
you want to keep that goose good and fat
and let it keep growing and outpacing
inflation
and that is what i'm doing
which you know and that's more than many
financial advisors can say yeah yeah
i can't tell you how many financial
advisors dave i've sat with and said
i want you to give me the exact
portfolio breakdown that you have for
your family
and the response is almost universally
well you know see
what we're doing here is this uh nope
what
ever you're doing with your family is
what i want to do in my house yeah i
don't i've never
told somebody to do something in 30
years of doing this that i don't do
yeah i never asked somebody live debt
free and then i was borrowing money
i don't have a super secret double back
flip family partnership limited
thing to it's a trick that the secrets
of the rich that nobody knows about
nope just got real estate no debt
that's boring money and mutual funds
just zero sex appeal
pretty comfortable with that
[Laughter]
pretty comfortable with that yeah that's
that's that's the new t-shirt dave
ramsey zero sex appeal
and i'm good with that yeah 700 several
hundred million dollars
i'm good with that all good pretty good
with that
uh yeah so that's that's the thing man
just are you gonna outpace inflation and
that that's where the theory breaks down
this is the dave ramsey show
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country
or have a better life the army national
guard can help get you there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
if you feel like you will always be
stuck paying off your debt i got good
news you're not
we're going to show you how to get out
because you will have extra money when
you get out
your most powerful wealth building tool
is your income and when you don't have
any bills you're ready to go baby
it doesn't have to be this way you don't
have to be stuck it won't take nearly as
long
as you think with ramsey plus we'll kick
you off with
90 days of guided help so you can put
more of your money
back in your bank account you're going
to get practical ways to get small
consistent wins every day that then add
up to the big results and
all new better habits right and that
means you're going to get where you want
to be
faster debt free building wealth
outrageous generosity to start ramsey
plus for free which of course includes
financial peace university and
includes the every dollar app premium
version everything is in ramsey plus if
you want to do a free
trial text the word trial 233
789 text trial 233
789 mark
is in providence hey mark welcome to the
dave ramsey show
hi dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
i have a question what are your thoughts
about investing
with family members my siblings uh
there's seven of us in a plot of land
you do not own the land the family
doesn't own the land and all seven of
you are going to go together as partners
to buy a piece of land
that's the idea yes it sounds like seven
opportunities to be angry
that's what i thought yeah i can't say
no fast enough or loud enough to this
tell your family you love them so much
you can't let everybody do this
just asking from i mean if it was just
you and
one sibling it would be fraught with
danger with seven
you can virtually guarantee it can't you
maybe i don't know yes i can
can guarantee it what what are seven
people gonna do with this land
it's more for maybe uh recreational
purposes and
if possible if a long term would be a
long term
uh maybe developing purposes
so let me tell you what happens it's
called the ds
okay the d's will kill you let me let me
give you some of the d's
drug use divorce disability
death disinterest default
i don't do my part dummies
they don't i'm just trying to help man i
don't know dogs
these things these d's will destroy this
and destroy your little plan and your
nirvana that you've got in your head
that this is going to be
i you you're asking what i think i
wouldn't do it
and uh i would recommend that you not do
it strongly as i possibly can
i've i've hunted on shared hunted land
before
and inevitably somebody's brother-in-law
has a friend who says hey nobody uses
this place on tuesdays it's cool
man and then they go and get shot at
well they do something stupid and then
it turns into a thing into a thing and
who took out to this and didn't air up
to that
it's just a mess and everybody's got
good intentions on the front end of it
it makes sense it's going to bring us
together we're going to have this thing
in our
family line forever until one person's
going to build on it
and then they're going to get a
coalition and they're not going to let
it just is a mess
you know junior wants to sell his part
out yeah i'm done i need the cash
and sister gets a divorce and now you're
now you're partners with her ex
right because the door because the judge
gave him your portion yep
and you bought your brothers and your
sister just gave you hers and now
you're going to war and it's just not
worth it it's just this is this is the
stuff i've heard for 30 years
that's why we have public parks go
recreate there yeah they're fun
or buy your own little track of land
yeah oh there's an idea
drake is with us in columbia south
carolina hi drake how are you
hey i'm doing well how are you better
than i deserve how can i help
um so i'm a 16 year old i'm still in
high school obviously i have about three
thousand dollars saved up
i just got my first car uh for about
five hundred dollars
it's worth about four thousand my mom's
frank gave me a very generous discount
very cool and um take dual enrollment
courses through
through my local technical school and i
should finish my associate's degree in
computer science before i graduate high
school
yeah way to go man thanks i was just
wondering
what my next step should be because i
know i don't really have a consistent
income right now i do have a job um but
as far as the baby steps go what should
i be focusing on or should i just be
educating myself in general
um well you are way ahead of the game
young sir you're you're you're on fire
you're
obviously got a game plan overall what
we teach folks is
even if you're super excelling like you
are while in high school and while
living at home
is the baby steps really don't apply
except i you know we have
we teach teenagers in the high school
curriculum to have a 500
emergency fund to still be on a budget
and they've got some steps that
that we use in the high school
curriculum but we don't
uh the the actual baby steps we talk
about here on this show
wouldn't apply until you're ready to
take a job and leave home
and that maybe after you graduate that
you want to go in the technical world
and so you go straight out of high
school with your associate's degree into
the technical world and so you may be
you know 18 19 years old
on your own and doing your thing and
then you'd work your baby steps
at that point but as far as our plan
goes that's what i would do but man he's
on fire
yeah one thing they've challenged me on
this
i always want 16 year olds to remember
to be 16 too
i want kids to remember to enjoy their
life
if if it's a life worth enjoying if
you've got friends you can hang out with
and throw a ball with or
there's a almost a barbell i'm seeing
with kids who just have cashed out
already 16 it's like the life's gonna be
over it is what it is
then there's another crew that are just
so focused on what tomorrow's going to
look like in the next day and the next
day and then what's next what's next
you just forget to be present and just
enjoy being 17
right well yeah hyper performance on
goals that
on overachieving right goals early
and to the point you car you don't
leaving carved out room for now
that's exactly right yeah that don't
know challenge on that i like that i
agree with that there's something about
i mean i worked my butt off when i was
in high school
i didn't because i liked making money i
did too and i would just i would
because i wanted to buy something yeah
uh and but also
you know had all the high school
experiences as well
um some of those i wish i could have
back i wasn't gonna say that
they're not free for that they're not
great
but there's something about being 17 and
being hanging out go to the lake go
fishing go do some stuff that are fun
man because
the the responsibilities once they hit
you man they don't ever stop
and at the same time man you are a great
influence i'm glad you're
growing up to lead the world that my
kids are going to grow up into because
we need more hearts and minds like yours
drake
you're killing it dude it's awesome very
well done washington dc
jeff's calling hi jeff how are you hey
thanks for having me on the program dr
laurie thank you sure
how can we help so i uh
knew uh a new listener i kind of found
you guys yesterday a friend pointed me
in the direction when i was complaining
about
debt and being in debt and um he said he
sounded like that guy dave ramsey and i
said ah was that the guy at your wedding
that didn't like him
um he said no no he got the radio
the other the other dave yeah the other
day so
uh here i am calling the other days um
and and looking for a little advice
there
um so i uh i
bought a house um and then i moved and
when i moved back to the area i love my
tenant so much that i bought another
house which is probably stupid
and then i thought i was moving so i
rented that house out and
now i'm moving in an apartment with two
houses and four hundred thousand dollars
in bed
so i don't really know what to do won't
you sell them um yeah
that's kind of what i was calling to
check and see if that's the right thing
to do i just didn't know
none of this what you described to me
happened by default
not by plan yes these houses are like
left over from plan changes they weren't
caused by i plan to live
have two rentals and live in an
apartment so you ended up with them by
accident so get rid of them on purpose
that's what i would do if i woke up in
your shoes i like rentals i mean i want
a bunch of real estate i want you to
have that if you want to own it someday
but i think these two things own you
right now taking up way too much of your
headspace and way too much of your money
and and you're really not making that
much on them you ain't getting equity
so if i'm in your shoes i'm dumping both
of them start my life fresh
clean slate baby wipe board here we go
game on
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers to recommend
blinds.com is no exception they offer
high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and
interior shutters with easy online
ordering free shipping
and a guaranteed perfect fit go to
blinds.com and take advantage of this
week's
special savings
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsay personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five you jump in we'll talk
about your life
and your money laura is with us laura is
in new york city and it says on my
screen miss laura you're debt-free
congratulations
yes sir way to go how much have you paid
off
34 732 dollars in five months
wow and your range of income during that
time
um my base salary as a teacher is 65 000
but i was able to kick it up to 110 000
with a whole bunch of side hustles
good for you what kind of debt was the
35
000 well very normal loans
um i had a leased car um i had cell
phone bills you know a little bit of
everything
so you're just like a normal person bro
completely
broke yeah way to go so what happened
five months ago that let you on fire
well it was um i actually found your
program march
6 2020 and had a nice
even plan to pay everything off by 2022
paying minimums on things doing extra
stuff you know i wasn't ready to go
gazelle and well you know what happened
um
march 12th i heard there was a pandemic
hey
we were hey laura me and dave were there
we were in manhattan when it looked like
a zombie movie
we were we were in manhattan doing a
press event and
and they shut new york down it was like
a fictional movie never forget that as
long as i lived like a zombie apocalypse
you might have heard just a minor
inconvenience yeah
his name's cuomo oh my god it was
unbelievable
yeah so so you shut up so then you got
you got you got your face slammed in the
pavement then what'd you do
um well i stood back up and i said well
all of the things i had relied upon
were not guaranteed so i needed another
way
and your plan was the way and a lot of
doordash and instacart was away
i worked about 70 hours a week every
single day
i traded in my leased car for a cash
civic
and i'm super proud of it now i love
this girl
i know how old are you
i'm 32. hold on you weren't just door
dashing
and all those things on top of a regular
job
you were doing it on top of a teacher's
job which is
go to school stay at home put this on
zoom hey don't everybody take it off
we're just going to mail our things
i i talk to teachers every day literally
where they're just breaking down into
tears collapsing i can't do it anymore
and then you would get off the last zoom
call with that last little kid and then
you'd go hit the streets to make more
money
how did you do this it's a coping
mechanism ah
there you go working yeah work as a
coping work therapy i like it
i'll go with work better than work
therapy's better than retail therapy
yes it creates income rather than
outgoing i'm gonna tell rachel cruz that
that's right
for sure i'm so proud of you lauren
you're incredible laura
so when your friends go oh my gosh girl
you doubled your income in a pandemic
and got out of debt in five months
because you went bananas
if you lost your mind what do you tell
them the the absolute
must do to get out of debt is what is it
you got to do what are the things you
have to do to get out of debt
wow um don't listen to anyone that says
you can't
there's a lot of messaging in our
society a lot of millennials feel like
we'll never
retire or buy a house and in a year
i've learned i can do that and will do
that and much more than that
hey will you run for president in 24
goodness no
wow that's amazing don't listen to the
messages
from the culture that says you're a
loser that says you can't
yeah so who do you teach
um i teach middle and high school
students music good
i'm glad you're out there spreading amen
positivity
and amen man i'm so happy you're there
so proud of you how does it feel now
that you're free
it feels lighter and actually yesterday
dave i just filed my taxes and filled up
my emergency fund
who was your biggest who was your
biggest cheerleader
i have a few pastor dan barton was my
financial peace coordinator
he's amazing he's out in arizona really
dedicated
to the program fantastic man amy green
is a financial peace coach
and i spoke with her over the summer as
well she's wonderful
um and you know my family and my
boyfriend yeah
and your family and your boyfriend
everybody cheering you on and yet there
are the negative messages and voices out
there that you just have to tune out and
you did it
you did it you did it you did it you did
it did you
ever i mean yeah i mean when you started
you
it's so funny that you started kind of
ish and then like the pandemic is what
fired you up
yeah so instead of putting it down the
challenge caused you to rise up
absolutely yeah that's just the way
you're that's where you're put together
kiddo man you're amazing
hey laura i'm laughing and cheering you
on kind of glossing over it
it was downright scary when you
experienced this wasn't it
it we were there in new york it was
scary that was awesome oh absolutely
yeah we were like we got to get to the
airport and get out of here these people
have lost their it was everlasting
it was scary and what put ever put the
listener who's driving their car right
now
they are doing another load of laundry
with earbuds in and they are exhausted
and they don't see life in the tunnel
you were at
literally at ground zero of this thing
as it spread throughout the united
states
what would you tell that person who's
terrified and scared and exhausted
every everything seems darker when you
can only see a foot in front of you
but you you can trust in yourself
and in god if you believe in god and
in the people around you and there's a
there's a light at the end that you
can't even see you don't even know
it's there and it's not keep walking
keep walking yeah right
good for you we got a copy of uh chris
hogan's book for you everyday
millionaires there's no question that
that's a chapter in your story coming up
you're an amazing young woman i'm so
proud of you very very well done
all right it's laura from new york city
35
000 paid off and get this five months
wow five months as a teacher five she
got rid of her lease car she's driving a
paid for civic she's door dashing she's
instagramming
she's a freaking rock star 65 000 almost
doubled her income up to 110
with the side hustles she kicks butt and
takes names
in a city they're not even allowed to
work in and she did anyway
because somebody's got to deliver the
freaking food and take care of those
kids
way to go laura count it down let's hear
a debt free scream
three two one i'm dad free
what a hero dude dave yesterday me and
my wife sat down and we came up with
this
with our schedule for for
knocking our mortgage out and this
person just poured some gasoline on that
fire man
you're just gonna go home and up the
schedule dude i i mean
what are you how are you gonna have any
excuse after listening to that
you know but but you know what she did
you got nothing
she's got a lease car she can't afford
you know what she did
she didn't freaking hesitate she got rid
of her she axed that thing
yes got a used civic you know what she
did with the civic
doordash yep you wanna shoot with a
civic instacart yep you know what she
did
she she showed up and taught anyway you
want to know what misery is
it's teaching middle school kids online
music lessons
[Laughter]
you think your job's bad try doing all
day
just try teaching middle school middle
school music online
and then going all right now it's time
to really get after it
after hours and then you get up the next
day all right timmy get out the vile
freaking lynn here we go again and then
your door dash
and then you go get laura what a stud
man man
and this is amazing this is dave my
mind's blown because you're not
even allowed to work in new york and she
didn't listen to the negativity the
honor
and instacart are there those those are
essential jobs so
i'm so proud don't get me started but
what a story man she figured you figure
out a way
what a story i'm gonna live my life in
fear and am i gonna live my life being
told i'm not gonna
leave the messages i'm not gonna believe
the messages
i don't like normal normal sucks i don't
be normal anymore she just declared it
five months boom over love it this
is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
our scripture today ii peter 1 21 for no
prophecy was ever produced by the will
of man but men
spoke from god as they were carried
along by the holy spirit
abraham lincoln said things may come to
those who wait but only the things left
by those who hustle i like that that's
good
dr john deloney ramsay personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five
dr deloney and rachel cruz will be doing
a money and
marriage live event live streamed on
february the 12th at 7 00 pm it is our
valentine's
event february the 12th you can get
tickets of course at daveramsey.com
event be sure and check them out they're
only 20 dollars so you ought to make
sure you make sure
it's good it's going to be awesome that
you're ready i mean that's like a week
from friday right it's gonna be good
yeah
i would i would take my wife on a date
to this event which means we'd just go
sit on the couch and turn the tv on
and we we'd get some food and it's it's
gonna be an awesome event i'm looking
forward to it there goes the live stream
love it all right annie's with us in
concord new hampshire hi annie welcome
to the dave ramsey show
hey thanks for taking my call um my
husband my husband and i are thinking of
leaving the east coast
and moving on to my family's ranch in
montana
cool and we're wondering yeah we're
wondering if we should sell our house
here in new hampshire or if we rent it
no you sell it you sell it because we'd
be 100
debt-free but we'd be living in an rv on
land we don't own
it's okay sell it sell it yeah
okay and then develop develop a plan
where you're not living in an rv
long term on land that you don't own
well that's another call that you don't
have time for right now
i mean you need to develop a plan that
does that because you don't want that
that's like it's an okay short term
thing but you don't be 10 years later
still living in a van down by the river
i mean that doesn't that's not a plan
so but you don't want a long-distance
landlord from montana to new hampshire
that's a good way to have somebody
change their harley oil in your living
room
yeah well we i'm eventually going to be
inheriting the land
okay that's fine but i'm just you're not
coming back to new hampshire and you're
not a long-distance landlord
if you were living in montana you would
never go hey let's buy rental property
in
new hampshire no you'd never do that
that's that's
not a good plan i think that's the first
time in the human language that sentence
has been uttered
you know what honey now that we're in
montana let's buy some let's buy some
property over in new hampshire yeah one
county over john's in pensacola hey john
how are you
good dave how you doing better than i
deserve how can we help
so what's the situation real quick
around about your test um so my mom was
65
my dad passed away about five years ago
from cancer and my mom is living off of
uh social security a little bit of what
he got from the navy's retirement and
then a smaller retirement from his
civilian job
um she still has a mortgage on her home
i don't know the exact amount it's
roughly like 120 130
and her house is in need of pretty
serious repairs
he didn't have any life insurance so
that he did have life insurance this is
where one of the big issues comes in mom
she had about 300 000 when he first died
minus funeral costs and stuff that is
all gone now
um through just buying random things she
didn't need
she bought a brand new car and
admittedly she gave it to some of the
family members which you know now i look
back and wish i had never accepted it
but i was
you know younger and not as wise with my
money
um so it's just my sister and i and i'm
trying to figure out how to help her but
the problem is
that she doesn't like to talk about it
she doesn't want our help basically
but she needs it i guess this is what
i'm trying to say
man i when you say she she doesn't want
your help
when you're talking about your adult
parent this is hard to hear
but she doesn't want your help
um yeah have you sat down and tried to
have a pointed conversation with her
or is it the normal
kind of a aggressive kind of walking
through the kitchen he kind of things
have you sat her down and said hey mom
we need to do some math on this
yeah well so so currently uh my wife and
i live in pensacola i'm in the navy
um we're from virginia so my mom lives
in virginia beach and my sister is still
with her
um so my sister deals with her directly
more than i do obviously um i have tried
to talk to her about it vaguely and
she i don't think she gets angry but she
you know she
it's it's almost that attitude of like
well you know you're my child right you
know
you should listen to me about stuff and
not the other way around yeah it's
awesome here's the deal man at some
point if i'm you
i'll just tell you what i would do i
would wait till i have a break
and i would let my mom know hey when we
come into town we're gonna have this
conversation
and okay i feel like i need to get all
of our ducks in a row
and i want to make sure that i can best
help you and be a good son
and she may say go jump in a lake at
which point
i wouldn't recommend you doing that but
at the end she's telling you we're done
with the conversation
you can then have a conversation with
your sister and you all make plans on
how you're going to proceed if and when
mom needs additional assistance and
support but
the hard part is man is your mom's an
adult and she gets to make adult
decisions
and yeah it's hard it's just not against
the law to be stupid
yeah yeah um hypothetical if she did
accept the help what would you in that
situation what would you recommend that
we do she doesn't have any savings at
all right now
um you hold on you have kelly pick up
and
um we'll sign her up for ramsey plus and
we'll teach her how to handle money
we'll put her on a budget get her out of
debt
teach her to live on lessons she makes
and makes why make wise money decisions
including starting to save
we'll teach her and show her how as a
matter of fact your family can go
through it together we'll pay for all of
it if you want to
and if you can get her to do it and you
know what you might do is say hey mom
i'm going through this class
on how to handle money and i want you to
go through with me
okay and i really appreciate it there's
so many things i didn't that
when dad passed away i didn't even know
i'm learning all this new stuff i'd love
for you to learn it with me
yeah one thing you can always do is it's
easier to
tell your story the things you're doing
and the experiences you're having
than it is to wag your finger at
somebody else and tell them what they
shouldn't be doing
and just be going mom i'm so i feel so
good right now we're on a budget we're
getting out of debt i feel
in control i felt stupid and i felt
insecure
and i felt out of you know weird and
everything else and man i got to tell
you
and i want you to go through this class
with me i'm gonna i've got it set up so
you can go through it free
and so you can start learning some of
this stuff because man it's changing my
life and
yeah and not mom you're so stupid and
you you burned through 300 grand you
need a class
that's right you know that's not going
to work because she is going to go
i powdered your butt and i really don't
need your opinion that's right the
powder butt syndrome kicks into
gear bridgette is with us bridget's in
savannah georgia bridget i'm short on
time go straight to your question
okay dave we're at the point now where
we're only owning about 20 000 on our
house
and we just sold a property and it
brought in 35
000 however recently
right across the street from us because
we're out kind of rule
the guy just started bringing in a bunch
of old mobile homes
and we're not in a position to sell i
mean to move or anything do we just pay
it on off and
what do we do at this point
why are you not in the position
well my husband lost his job with no
covet situation
and he just got a job like two weeks ago
yeah but i mean we got
here you got a paid for house what would
the property bring if you sold it
well it was valued at 210 why can't you
take 210 000
and go buy something else we got two
kids with cash flowing in college
so it's kind of what's that got to do
with it start it
you got 210 000 in your hand because you
just sold your house why can you not go
buy another house with that
well i guess we could and i just didn't
know what to do without talking today
yeah well i mean i'm not telling you you
got to move but if the trailers are
going to muck up everything across the
street you got to get out of there right
right right you don't want to live in
the middle of that is the neighbor
somebody you can pay that off
it doesn't matter because you're getting
ready to sell it yeah is
the neighbor somebody you can have a
conversation with
well i'm not really sure he's from
florida and so it's
we all live on like five or six acres of
peace out here
and so he just came in and purchased and
start bringing in mobile homes out here
so yeah i've i've got
i live i live in a similar situation and
i've got a couple of neighbors i can
talk to and a couple that i can't
and if it's somebody you can go knock on
their door and just get to meet them and
see how they're doing it may be
a great conversation to have before you
go run and sell your house
yeah but i mean he might be parking them
there for two months and then going to
move them back out that's right
you may probably ought to find out the
details of what's happening that's not a
bad plan but
bottom line is nobody said you got to
stay if the neighborhood's going to go
bad
you don't want to stay that puts us hour
today ramsey showing the books we'll be
back with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace
and that's to walk daily with the prince
of peace christ jesus
[Music]
you